[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
écoutez tout est sous contrôle mais on
vous demande de sortir il est arrivé un
petit incident malheureux alors en
quittant tranquillement je crois que
c'est ce qu'on peut faire de mieux
c'était il y a 10 ans 4 septembre 2012
bien sûr l'attentat du Métropolis
cette semaine vous avez suivi cette
controverse le CF Montréal engagé Sandro
grindé je vous remontre ce qu'il avait
écrit ce soir-là il y a 10 ans donc un
tweet qui avait été extrêmement violent
la seule erreur que le tireur a commise
la nuit dernière c'est de rater sa cible
Marois la prochaine fois mon gars
j'espère
syndrogende il y a 10 ans madame Marois
est avec nous Pauline Marois bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur vous allez bien
je vais très bien merci malgré tout ce
qui vient se passer qui est un très très
mauvais souvenir vous en conviendrez
bien surtout avec les propos qu'on a
rappelé et qui continuent d'être
condamnable à tous égales mais justement
quand vous avez appris cette semaine
qu'on que le CF Montréal avait offert un
poste d'entraîneur sur l'équipe
auxiliaire votre première réaction cette
école
ma première réaction ça a été c'est pas
possible ça se peut pas on peut pas
donner une telle responsabilité
à un homme qui a tenu de tel propos et
dont il ne s'est jamais formellement
excusée
et ça ça re-brancé beaucoup de choses
chez moi parce que je me dis que comme
société on a toujours on a toujours été
en désaccord avec la violence avec
évidemment les agressions auprès de
personnes qui sont en autorité qu'elles
soient de simples citoyens c'est pas la
société québécoise et je peux ajouter
cependant que ça a été un bon moment
quand même cette semaine mardi pourquoi
c'est un bon moment parce que la société
québécoise
c'est solidarisé autour du fait qu'elle
devait dénoncer une telle situation et
c'est venu de tous les milieux les
milieux politiques les milieux
médiatiques les citoyens qui se sont
manifestés de toutes sortes de façon
alors c'est rassurant à point de vue
quand ça nous valeurs et quant à la
suite des choses mais ce qui était pas
rassurant c'est que le CF procède à
cette nomination comme si d'analyser
finalement les propos que celui-ci avait
tenu c'était pas acceptable et ça ne
sera jamais dans les sociétés
démocratiques comme celles dans laquelle
on vit on le sait ce réflexe là dont
vous parlez effectivement il a été il a
été immédiat une année puis les gens
disent ça a pas de bon ça ça vous dites
c'est le bon côté par ailleurs la zone
d'ombre et je crois que vous avez déjà
dit à plusieurs reprises madame Marois
que on n'a pas pris la mesure de ce qui
est arrivé à l'époque vous vous ne
vouliez pas en faire une histoire vous
vouliez pas faire du millage comme on
dit avec ça donc vous avez peut-être
vous avez minimisé ce qui est arrivé ce
soir là c'est encore votre sentiment
n'est-ce pas
absolument Patrick vous êtes c'est tout
à fait juste je l'ai dit à quelques
reprises dans les derniers mois
je ne voulais pas utiliser cet événement
là avant qu'on a posé aussi un jugement
sur la personne si elle avait des
problèmes de santé mentale ou quoi que
ce soit
elle s'était manifestée en faisant
référence à la société anglophone à la
communauté anglophone je voulais pas
exacerber les relations que nous avions
avec la communauté de anglophone
évidemment un mouvement souverainiste un
gouvernement souveraineté ça a jamais
été toujours ça pas toujours été facile
même si on a toujours très bonne
relation avec la société
anglo-québecoise mais j'ai sous j'ai
sous-évalué l'événement j'ai voulu un
peu
nier le tout pensez à autre chose faire
en sorte qu'on s'apaisantise pas sur ça
mais je crois que je n'aurais pas dû
faire ça j'aurais plutôt dû mettre en
lumière c'était un geste violent
qu'aucune société de devrait accepter
on s'attaquait à la démocratie dans le
fond ça aurait pu être quelqu'un d'autre
que moi mais dans l'occurrence c'est moi
comme femme souverainiste mais je venais
d'être élu légitimement le mouvement
souveraineté c'est un mouvement
d'ailleurs profondément démocratique
tout à fait légitime comme n'importe
quel autre orientation politique il y a
jamais eu d'attentats comme cela à
travers le Canada mais on s'est attaqué
donc à moins au mouvement souverainiste
et c'était inacceptable condamnable et
j'aurais dû être plus j'aurais dû
intervenir davantage à ce moment-là pour
dénoncer la situation mais encore une
fois je l'expliqué ce matin à Monsieur
Arcan que quand on est une femme élue
souvent on nous examine sous l'angle de
la capacité qu'on va avoir quand on va
avoir de faire face à des situations
difficiles d'être un peu au dessus de la
mêlée je sais que je suis capable de ça
mais je sentais comme le probablement le
besoin de d'envoyer un message comme
quoi je suis en contrôle ce qui était
vrai dans un sens et je ne me laisserai
pas atteindre par ça mais dans les faits
c'était peut-être pas l'attitude à avoir
mais je l'ai eu à ce moment je comprends
tout à fait et par ailleurs est-il
normal qu'on est dû attendre une
poursuite civile en cours supérieure
pour avoir un examen plus précis des
manquements graves du service de la
Sûreté du Québec et de la police de
Montréal il a fallu avoir une procédure
civile il y a pas eu de grande enquête
non plus
c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il y a pas eu
de grande enquête mais probablement que
c'était aussi dans la foulée que ce que
je viens d'expliquer au sens où comme
j'avais minimisé l'événement on n'a pas
investigué beaucoup la situation et puis
j'étais à la tête d'un gouvernement
minoritaire j'avais beaucoup de projets
en tête je voulais faire avancer des
dossiers je reviendrai pas sur la face à
un des dossiers d'électrification des
transports j'en ai long comme ça et donc
on s'est attardé à la tâche c'est
investi dans la tâche et finalement on
n'est pas revenu sur l'événement sous
l'angle de ce que vous soulignez ce qui
est aussi peut-être aurait dû être fait
mais j'assume j'étais là et j'ai agi au
mieux compte tenu des circonstances oui
bien sûr et est-ce que vous avez la
certitude aujourd'hui que néanmoins les
forces policières ont pris des notes
puis on fait d'abord ils ont fait un mea
culpa mais ils ont changé les procédures
il y a eu trois campagnes depuis au
Québec qui se sont relativement bien
déroulés là
je ne peux
pas comprendre pas que il n'est pas fait
le travail nécessaire pour corriger les
lacunes que l'on a pu voir dans les
derniers dernières analyses qui se sont
faits devant la cour ou autrement parce
que ça reste des gens très responsables
sagesse ça reste une des services de
sécurité des services policiers
professionnels de haut niveau mais comme
je vous le disais il y en avait jamais
eu d'attentats à l'égard d'une personne
politique qui avait eu des problèmes des
des grands événements évidemment comme
Polytechnique naturel l'Assemblée
nationale mais un attentat politique
contre une personne politique il n'y en
avait jamais eu alors il y avait
probablement un certain relâchement dans
un sens ou on prenait pour acquis que ça
allait bien se passer mais dans les
faits il y aurait fallu resserrer
davantage toutes les règles de sécurité
pour que ils ne passent pas au travers
les mains du filet parce que c'est ce
qui est arrivé ce soir-là
vous étiez pas il y avait pas assez de
gens autour de vous pour vous protéger
madame Marois le steak claire
je vais vous raconter autre chose que
j'ai déjà
dit dans le passé mais vous savez
j'étais en face du Métropolis je devais
passer à pied du Théâtre du Nouveau
Monde où on avait un petit local pour
atteindre les résultats vers le
Métropolis et finalement mon attacher de
presse me dit ben écoutez il pleut
madame Marois peut-être pas une bonne
idée je l'avais vu sur la scène je peux
tout croche alors on va prendre la
voiture je pense que c'est ce qui nous a
sauvé la vie parce qu'il était dans la
rue il était là et
même ma famille était avec moi mon
conjoint mes enfants ma mère et puis
finalement il s'est rabattu sur autre
chose il est allé évidemment derrière le
Métropolis marqué que heureusement
heureusement que son arme c'est un rayé
parce que ça aurait été un véritable
carnage il y avait du monde en écouler
malheureusement il y a déjà eu mord
d'hommes avec Denis Blanchet dès le
courage qui a été lourdement à café
blessé et qui a subi même les
conséquences aujourd'hui
alors voilà mais j'espère que ça amènera
nos services de sécurité qui sont quand
même des gens des professionnels à
resserrer le les outils qu'ils utilisent
et la sécurité dans ont besoin les
personnes politiques madame Marois merci
beaucoup je vois l'image est brouillée
ben ça j'allais vous remercier j'allais
vous merci Madame Marouane nous avons
parlé au plaisir pour une autre entrevue
portez-vous bien
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI